gram staining is a frequently used  technique in microbiology labs in the  gram staining we start by smearing the  cells on the slide heat fixing them  eventually then the primary strain is  basically Crystal Violet which attach to  the cell wall of the bacteria then we  use a modern solution which is generally  iodine it allows the crystal Violet to  be trapped in the cell walls  then there is a decolorization step  which is done by ethanol or acetone wash  eventually there is a count staining by  saffronine gram-positive bacteria will  take a violet color whereas gum negative  bacteria will take a pink color so this  is visualized under the microscope and  this particular technique is very useful  for clinical diagnosis as well watch the  full video to know more